the falls first nor'easter is bringing
gusty winds heavy rains and flood
warnings to many parts of the East Coast
it's also expected to cause havoc with
the nation's air traffic today Kenneth
Craig is on the waterfront in Manasquan
New Jersey where the weather is already
kicking up Kenneth good morning sounds
like it's picking up so bad maybe we are
missing it Craig at this point in time
we have to get back weather good
Michelle good morning I'm from the
Jersey Shore and make no mistake we are
in the thick of this storm this morning
this is an area of major concern and
this is one of the many reasons why take
a look behind me you can see these
houses right here right on the other
side right on the other side of this
road right here is the ocean and these
homes are totally unprotected the wind
has been battering this coastline for
hours as you can see and the rain
started overnight as it did for much of
the East Coast as millions of residents
experienced their first nor'easter of
the season gale warnings are in effect
from North Carolina all the way up to
Maine in some areas including where we
are in New Jersey could see wind gusts
today of upwards of 60 miles an hour but
it's not just the wind that's the
concern today it's also the potential
for rain many people are going to see
anywhere from 1 to 2 inches of rain and
in some places upwards of 3 inches and
while most of us will see just rain some
places in New England and in upstate New
York could see winter weather from this
snow accumulation and even some ice
flash flood warnings are in effect from
where I am right now in New Jersey all
the way up to Massachusetts
and there is the concern Michelle for
major localized flooding all right
Kenneth Craig Inman asked why New Jersey
oh poor guy we've all been there
definite sympathy forget it this morning
waiting hoping you can hear this thing
you know right better him than us